foreign
[Music]
a customer engineer at Google Cloud
welcome back to the technical series for
startups where we are creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups to start build and grow
their businesses successfully and
sustainably on Google Cloud
in the previous episode we share with
you how to manage apis with fpg
today we are moving on to our 11th stop
which is on security deep dive in this
video we are going to cover introduction
to the security comment Center
top use cases of security comment Center
that you can use in your security
operations life cycle based on your
organization's needs
and demo
lastly activity security capabilities
well come on let's head right on and
explore together
how can we detect malicious activities
in the Google Cloud environment
the Google Cloud solutions that we will
be focused on during this session are
security comment Center also known as
SCC and activeassist
SCC is inspired by the same technologies
that Google uses to protect itself we
are now bringing this Cloud native
technology to the market so that you can
utilize it to protect your organization
as you move from your private
installations to public Cloud typically
what we hear are four major concerns the
first is really the change in visibility
and control you see from what you have
when you are in on-prem to when you are
in the public Cloud secondly as you add
and grow into a public Cloud rely on new
systems new controls and new things to
learn and that inconsistency between
what you are used to and what's running
in public Cloud also creates
opportunities for misconfigurations
thirdly on an ongoing basis you need to
demonstrate that you are maintaining
compliance or transparency to your
management your Auditors and even
yourself
lastly the inability for you to detect
and respond to the threats that you see
in your systems at the same rate with
the same kind of details that you have
in the past
because of these kind of main concerns
we really focus on creating the security
comment Center to give you one central
place across your organization so how
does security Command Center work
as you can see in this slide SEC
continuously monitors your Google Cloud
environment to discover assets identity
misconfigurations and web application
vulnerabilities and detect threats in
near real time
SEC also provides you these capabilities
for you to effectively manage security
and risks
there is an SF view that provides a
real-time view of your resources and
policies changes to your inventory and
the security findings associated with
each of those assets
you get security findings that span
across misconfigurations vulnerabilities
and threats to your gcp environment
it gives you a prioritized security
findings field that helps you to address
potential security issues
another capability within SCC is a
compliance view compliance view enables
you to view and know where you stand by
correlating all its track
misconfigurations and vulnerabilities to
Industry standard like CIS PCI DSS list
853 and ISO 27001.
it also provides compliance reporting
segmented by these standards that you
can use to track how your environment
Compares with the technical controls of
this industry recommended benchmarks
SCC provides you recommendations and
recommendation steps for you to take
action on the security findings and
compliance violations you can also send
the findings to a store or CM platform
for you to remedy and respond
there was a brief overview of the SEC
let's look into SCC use cases for
further details
here are the top use cases of security
Command Center that you can use in your
security operations life cycle based on
your organization's needs all these use
cases will help you improve your
security posture on Google Cloud
let's walk through each of these use
cases in security Command Center so as I
said security Command Center is designed
to give you a single organizational
level view of the resources and assets
you've deployed into gcp you can see all
the different resources that have been
deployed broken down by asset type and
you can identify the changes that have
been made in those resources over time
to help you prevent threats Cloud SEC
shows you resources that have been
misconfigured and provides
recommendations on how to fix them
before an attacker can exploit them with
security health analytics you can
identify misconfigure virtual machines
containers network storage and identity
and access management policies
SCC also has web security scanner it can
automatically scan to detect key
vulnerabilities in app engine compute
engine and Google kubernetes engine
applications before deploying them to
production including those from
categories in the uwas top 10 such as
cross-size creating use of clear text
passwords and outdated libraries
SCC also helps report on and maintain
compliance with the ability for security
health analytics to perform continuous
compliance monitoring identifying
resources that are known to be
misconfigured against compliant controls
from such as CIS Benchmark PCI DSS ISO
2001 needs 853 and more these findings
are surfaced through dashboard that can
be filtered and scoped by projects or
folders this gives you control over how
you assess your environment these
reports can be a starting point for
remediation actions or export it out as
a CSP that can be used to track your
compliance status over the time
lastly with SCC you detect threats
targeting your Google Cloud Assets in
Cloud the thread landscape looks a
little bit different than it does
on-prem so in the cloud there are some
things you may recognize such as malware
pitching use of resources to commit
outgoing videos but some of these are
more prevalent and more powerful in the
cloud with event threat detection which
we've built on externalized version of
internal locks processing pipeline that
Google uses to protect itself to protect
you in the cloud
it watches Cloud logging stream to
detect threats like Brute Force SSH
Cloud IM abuse malware and data
exploration
now let's talk about one of our
customers and how security comment
Center has allowed them to protect their
Cloud environment
currency develops and operates the
Crusty educational platform the platform
is used by more than 3 000 Junior and
senior high schools across Japan
security comment Center is integrated
into Crusty's ticket management system
chess system and mobile utilizing pops
up and Cloud functions the moment
security Command Center detects a
vulnerability or misconfiguration it
automatically integrates with Crusty's
ticket management system to register a
ticket
simultaneously its chess system then
notifies the administrator of the
project affected by the alert
Mr Ito the data scientist and general
manager data AI Department of grassy
told us that the entire company is more
secure as a result of this initiative
not just the data ER department and by
making full use of the security Command
Center mechanism they are developing
more robust Services now let's take a
quick tour to the console in this demo
we'll explore how to get started with
SCC first we should set up Cloud IEM
permissions to get started you need to
ensure you have correct permissions in
Cloud IEM first we should set up Cloud
IAM permissions
to get started you need to ensure you
have correct permission set up in cloud
iam
to set up security command center for
the first time you need the following
identity and access management roles
organization admin
security Center admin
security admin
and service account creator
once you complete the IAM settings now
we can enable services
once you complete the IEM settings now
we can choose services
to dish soap head to the console on the
left hand panel
navigate to security
and then
click security Command Center
on the organization drop down list
please select your organization
then click on settings
and you can see all built-in services
are enabled by default at the
organization level
each service scans all supported
resources and reports findings for your
entire organization
disable any of the services
click manage settings
you can enable or disable a service for
your entire organization
or select folders and projects
note settings will inherit from parent
resources unless overwritten on child
resource our built-in services are
security health Analytics
which provides managed vulnerability
assessments getting that automatically
detects the highest severity
vulnerabilities and misconfigurations
for your Google Cloud assets web
security scanner which identifies
security vulnerabilities in your app
engine Google kubernetes engine and
compute engine web application
event threat detection which uses log
data from inside your systems and
monitors your organization's Cloud
logging stream to detect threads
container threat detection continuously
monitors the state of container
optimized OS node images
the service evaluates all changes and
remote access attempts to detect runtime
attacks in near real time
VM threat detection is a managed service
that scans enabled compute engine
project and VM instances to detect
unwanted applications running inside VMS
you can also integrate with other
services to have their findings surfaced
in the security Command Center for
example Cloud anomaly detection cloth
armor claw DLP and for steady security
from Google Plus Security Service
offerings
now the security Command Center is ready
to help you prevent detect and respond
to threats
last step let's view dashboards time to
see the dashboards
the security command center dashboard
displays a comprehensive overview of
potential security risk findings
when you go to the security Command
Center the overview tab is displayed
the overview tab provides you with a
summary of the most severely rated
findings in your organization
so you can prioritize fixes new threats
over time shows the account of nutrients
detected per day
it provides hourly totals for findings
new threats over time shows the account
of nutrients detected per day
it provides hourly totals for findings
active vulnerabilities over time by
severity is a graphic display that shows
changes to vulnerabilities
additional tables display findings
grouped by category
asset type and project the tables that
you view the number of times each
vulnerability was detected and your most
impacted resources
on the threats dashboard you can review
potentially harmful events in your
organization's Google Cloud resources
these resources are summarized by
severity
category
and resource or project
the threat dashboard displays reserved
for the time period you specify in the
drop down list
you can click these items to see more
detail on the specific findings
the vulnerabilities dashboard displays
security health analytics findings and
recommendations
you can filter finding by project
category asset type and or benchmarks
the recommendation column provides a
summary of how to remediate the findings
the compliance dashboard helps you
review your high level violations status
and Export reports
this dashboard provides summaries for
the number of detectors associated with
each compliance standard including CIS
benchmark
and PCI DSS
that security health analytics and web
security scanner monitor
it is not a replacement for a compliance
audit but can be used to help you
maintain your continuous compliance and
catch violations only
you can filter the compliance dashboard
by project
and viewer export reports of specific
findings by compliance regime
if you like to export security column
Center data including assets and
findings
you can find the export button on the
assets or
findings tab on the dashboard
now let's talk about active assist
security capabilities active assist is
not just one thing it's a portfolio of
tools and services that span across
Google Cloud
activities combines data intelligence
and machine learning to provide you with
an array of tools specifically tuned to
your usage
these tools are designed to reduce the
complexity of managing infrastructure in
the cloud
the active assist portfolio includes the
recommendation Hub and an API as well as
a collection of recommenders
with active assist you can proactively
identify security gaps and maintain best
practices
you are able to use identity and access
management role recommendations to help
make your organization more secure by
reducing the number of permissions that
were over granted for the networking
layer firewall inside can provide you
access to insights recommendations and
metrics about your firewall rules for
example you can identify unused firewall
rules that can potentially allow
unwanted access and present of major
security risk to your organization
also with the firewall optimization
insights you can get insights on things
like unreachable and misconfigured rules
that may be redundant
using the connectivity test feature from
the network Intelligence Center you can
simulate the impact of configuration
changes as you apply them
this gives you confidence in a couple of
especially tricky scenarios where you
earn 100 sure if it is okay to remove a
particular fire role for example
finally to protect sensitive data and
power users who present a higher
security risk if their identities are
compromised the account security
recommender prompts Google Cloud project
owners to protect their account with
their Pawn's built-in security key
so as you can see active assist can help
you reduce attack surface and get you
much closer to the zero trust
environment
all in all Google cloud is able to
support your security needs and we hope
that this has given you a good
understanding and how you can secure
your Google Cloud environment using
security Command Center and active
assist
and if after this session you cannot get
enough of security Command Center and
active assist and are Keen to learn more
about these two check out the
suggestions here and links in the
description box
in our next episode you'll be learning
about Cloud tasks and Cloud scheduler
don't forget to like And subscribe to
our YouTube channel click on the Bell
icon to get notified each time a new
video is posted
thank you stay tuned and we'll see you
very soon in the next video
[Music]